okay welcome everybody uh i'm here with
uh alex you and uh jason and today we
are gonna learn how to make a paper
airplane with origami alex is an expert
this is what he's created he's got some
awesome designs that he's gonna do
another one later on but the the orange
plane is my logo and i met alex at an
event here in toronto and uh i said you
gotta come and teach me how to do a
people airplane organic so this is what
we're all here to learn and hopefully uh
we can pick it up quickly i have a bit
of a spring wrist
from snowboarding
and alex said as long as you can move
your fingers we can do this so
so we'll see how it goes first of all
thank you for having me evan and jason
um i'm alex i'm a healer i'm an origami
artist it's my passion to create things
from papers
so i'm just here to share
some teaching on how to create this
plane
here we go so we all have uh how big is
this like and this is eight and a half
inches and a half first of all we have
this square here fold it in half edge to
edge into a rectangle
as you see we just made a crease here
rotate the paper so the crease is
vertical
fold edge to edge again into a rectangle
now uh bring your lower right corner
point it to this crease here
i have a question is it half way
like
like where on this crease um
like if you want from the from the edge
point it to it first and i'll show you
later okay so right there yes and then
looking at the top right corner you want
to make sure this corner is sharp
okay
oh that's that's
precise man well i'm stressed out over
getting my corner exactly here you need
to stress as long as you follow your
plan which is your pre-creasing you'll
be fine there we go i think we got it
the corner is the reference point that's
how you know where to fold once we got
that we open it
so repeat the same process on the left
hand side so the lower left corner raise
it up and point it to the horizontal
crease
once you point it there match up on the
top left corner making sure that it's
sharp
this is probably trickiest part in
tarpon i kept it very clean and simple
but design because the logo is a very
clean and very give our very free feel
so i try to keep the design clean oh
yeah that's so good
origami is an art form combined with
matte is a very personal thing
so as you can see we just made through
an intersecting crease
right
and looking at the bottom part um
i want you to
fold this part up because the mark is
where the crease cross
pull that part up so the result would be
these two creases matching up with the
true um these are like deep juices too
right they're really pushing into it yes
i feel like my creases aren't
over the years i read some article on
how
how your fingers your nerve endings and
by folding it with your nails is
actually stimulating certain
brain uh area to grow oh you folded the
nails yeah wow
i missed that part so i fold the lower
right
edge matching up with this crease here
fold it
straight to that crease
uh it's what we call an angle bisector
we're dividing the angle into half
dividing this this angle and then you
should have a straight point at the end
there yeah straight point bottom
so oh the other side why behind here man
inside is not racist
on the right hand side this whole flap
just fold it to the center
flip it over
this is a good looking plane so far
right it's very clean yeah yeah it's
nice i like it the whole thing you have
like you're closing a book as always i'm
a student
so do you do classes i do
um i teach at um well i use teacher
libraries
birthday parties weddings this weekend
i'm teaching at um
the market village mall in markham for
chinese new year oh cool that's pretty
cool yeah
it's the year of the what horse can you
do a horse
uh i can
just not for my
head fair enough so um next part
oh um this piece
um
at a one third angle
well hold on i wanna i wanna ask is it
more to one side or the other um
oh i see yeah you're gonna have like a
thin yeah
if this is what forms the underside of
the plane so you're more like a mechanic
w now we have a reference point yes
oh is it is it um we want to raise your
wings
a bit
so you can rise yeah
my plane is going to ride i would say
170 degree angle at 180. a different
scale of wing length versus the body
with different effects on the
aerodynamics oh i haven't quite figured
out the exact detail yet but it'll work
okay so i have like a huge body on mine
yes
you have like a
slim line you know slimline body
it's all good oh yours is yours is
pretty big man yeah mine is like yours
is pretty big
from the back mine's like a dark power
the instruction for holding the plane is
hold it see this part is thicker right
so we want to fold it around the thin
part when you throw do you want to tilt
it at a slightly upper angle not
downward like this okay
and uh go ahead alex is going to demo
the proper way to throw
and and then jason and i are going to
face off
to see who made the better people
already launched so it's all looking at
the plane holding at the back where it's
thinner in paper
uh just two fingers and turn it slightly
upward by throwing
and here we go oh that's pretty good
that was pretty good that was nice that
was pretty good on three okay one
two
three
oh snap i think mine was
if i went further it totally went
further man now
alex is going to demonstrate how he
makes one of his own designs which is
what is it again a phoenix he's going to
make a phoenix it was his own design and
he's going to show us quickly how he
does it this is going to take him about
half an hour to do but we're going to
speed it up so you can see the whole
process
do
very cool thank you alex where can
people learn more about you you can
visit my website at
www.magicianofpaper.blogspot.com
or look me on facebook folding with you
my last name yue on facebook you can see
my work and um this event
so thanks for watching if you guys like
this video please give it a thumbs up
below let me know what you think about
the video in the comment section that we
sped up alex going through
making this phoenix
while
we were going through that there was a
lot of interesting conversation there's
me singing in chinese there's a whole
bunch of fun stuff happening if you want
to hear the whole thing unedited it's
about
20 minutes
let me know in the comments if we get
enough comments we'll post the unedited
version even though it's kind of
embarrassing
so uh thank you guys you want to see
more videos like this subscribe to the
channel and we'll see you soon